this is Startalk david terrazas asks
what does a rocket push against in space
to gain momentum or navigate Oh mass
that's yours that's what we do in space
and it's a great question because if you
know you don't have any gravity so when
you navigate your spaceship you need to
point it in different directions there's
a couple ways to do it
Hubble Space Telescope for example has
no fuel on board so it is not rocket it
turns which is it no there's no one
there to push it is nobody said no
fueled you didn't say no little kids
it's reaction no lion it's what we its
reaction with what's reaction wheels
reaction wheel spin via any a big
control moment gyros which is kind of
the same thing on the on the space
station these things spins you know they
spin up and they creates a reaction and
that reaction creates an opposite
reaction
spin them in there in a certain order in
a certain direction and you'll get a
reaction in the other direction and the
thing will point where you are they sort
of gyroscopes is exactly spending that's
one way the other way we did on the
space shuttle and on other space ships
do this in fact the space station has us
on the Russian and what we call
thrusters what is it's it's gas could be
nitrogen could be something else yeah
but just a guess you can't hear them in
space can here it is you hear it inside
of the spaceship shaking it yes yes sir
you rush ters were released there again
it'll cause or yeah it'll cause an
action mm-hmm which is the release of a
gas and a little little rocket and
you'll have a reaction the other way so
on the Space Shuttle we had large and
small thrusters different different
varieties all over the spaceship mainly
in the front at the nose and in the back
that you would fire to get the correct
orientation like you have the steering
wheels on a car and yes exactly you can
steer all you want you're not gonna go
anywhere your control surfaces do not
work because there's no air when you're
coming down in the shuttle even what
caused it looked like an airplane yeah
it will not be active until you pick up
atmosphere so the way you turned and
pointed thence and steered that Space
Shuttle yeah was with these little
little thrusters that would fire just
the one
gravity but let me attack exactly let me
back up on this question back up is
there anything to push against and the
whole idea when you watch the rocket
leave the ground it gives it gives you
the impression that the flames and gases
are pushing against the earth but that's
not really what's going on
you're throwing gas hot gas out the back
of the rocket so fast that the reaction
is the rocket goes off in the other
direction stand on a skateboard and
throw a bowling ball to your best friend
or and maybe your enemy and you will
find that the skateboard goes off in the
other direction rice works whether or
not you're on the earth or in space so
basically the rocket fuel is just the
biggest bowling ball weak increase and
it goes fast more or less all right we
don't throw it out our enemies this is
Startalk